the most powerful Cyclone to hit the
bear Bengal in the last 10 years is
crossing the coast of Bangladesh in
Myanmar strong winds and rainfall
Unleashed by the category 5 storm have
forced hundreds of thousands of people
to move to safer areas Barbara and gopa
has this report
residents in kyoc Tau are beginning a
cleanup after Cyclone Moka barreled
through Western Myanmar and Southern
Bangladesh
the storm had weakened by late Sunday
sparing rohingya refugee camps close to
its path
strong wind and I'm 51 years old this is
my very first experience with this there
were storms previously but not as strong
as this one I didn't think this would
happen
the storm built over the Bay of Bengal
on Tuesday before making landfall on
Sunday
strong winds up pretty trees and toppled
power lines some livelihoods are in
Ruins
I run a shop here the shop has been
blown away by the storm I have a beetle
nut Garden but it has also been
destroyed I have seen the Cyclones of
1991 and 1994 but today's was more
dangerous
better forecasting in recent years has
reduced death tolls during Cyclones
Cyclone largest devastated Myanmar in
2008 killing more than 100 000 people
thousands of people died in 2007 after
cycling sitter hit Southern Bangladesh
this time authorities say they moved
three-quarters of a million people to
safety before the storm
Al Jazeera
time Vegeta has more now from Cox's
Bazaar in Bangladesh
Bangladesh has been spared the main
threat of the Cyclone mocha by the time
it made landfall here the wind speed was
barely 120 kilometer per hour and you
can still see the wind is still on it's
a peripheral wind and heavy rain it hit
the San Martin island there's some
damages one person was still there by
falling tree that's the unconfirmed
report by our contact from journalists
staying there there's been some damage
on chat for deep nearby as for the
rohingya camp we know there's been no
major damages our contacts said to you
how to add damage they're already
repairing it there was no Landslide or
flood so they also have been spared from
this trust of this Cyclone now the
government and the rescue and Red Cross
and others gonna assess the damage it
may take a couple of days or even weeks
because many of the fishermen lives in
scattered islands in the coastal areas a
lot of the people who live in the
coastal areas are in the success the
most likely will lose all their
aquaculture farmland and other crops
those are major damage for the poor
people living by the coastline it takes
months and year for them to get back on
their feet unless they get help from the
government or other Aid agencies we yet
have to see what are the real damage
within next few days or even weeks